So that completes the last portion of this
lesson module, where we visited the structure of parallel
operating systems and in particular looked at tornado as
a case study. This completes the second major module
in the advance operating systems course, namely parallel systems.
I expect you to carefully read the papers we
have covered in this module which I've listed in
the required readings for the course, and which served
as the inspiration for the lectures that I gave you in this module. I want
to emphasize once more the importance of reading
and understanding the performance sections, of all the
papers. Both to understand the techniques and methodologies
therein, even if the actual results may not
be that relevant due to the dated nature
of the systems on which they've been implemented.